hey youtubers is Charlie in a bunch of
pictures just leaked from episode 7 so
JJ Abrams has been reacting in a really
funny way it kind of makes me think that
the leak might have been orchestrated
but whether or not that's the case I'm
just gonna do a breakdown of what's
going on with production they also just
hired josh trank to direct one of the
other spin-off movies and there's this
special Star Wars event happening on
Thursday I'm gonna do a full breakdown
of all that stuff if you're finding me
for the first time I do Star Wars bonus
videos every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything I was originally gonna
do my top 10 characters I wanted to see
come back but since this Millennium
Falcon thing happened I'm just gonna
push that video to next week so lots of
awesome Star Wars stuff to talk about
let's start with JJ Abrams a bunch of
pictures from the Tatooine set leaked as
well as pictures of a big Millenium
Falcon and x-wing props under
construction regardless of whether or
not the leaks were intentional JJ Abrams
posted this picture to Twitter as a
clever way to say he's really pissed
about the leak but yes the Millennium
Falcon is in the movie
that's the chessboard from inside the
Millennium Falcon underneath that note
of his so just out of respect I'm not
gonna post the leaked pictures here in
this video as big a deal as it was Yahoo
movies reported the Falcon was gonna be
in the movie a long time ago so it's not
really new news but there is a certain
spectacle to sing it in real life as for
production status they just wrapped in
Abu Dhabi that's where the Tatooine set
is and move back to London they're
actually shooting on the same stone
stage as the original trilogy and where
they shot Avengers 2 they even added two
more big actors to the cast
Gwendoline Christie who plays Brienne on
Game of Thrones and Lupita Nyong'o
we don't know who they're playing but
the best theory I've seen is that Lupita
is playing a Sith Warrior like asajj
ventress
and I really hope that Brienne gets to
be a Jedi Knight on Game of Thrones it's
all her character wants to be Brienne
just wants to be a knight but she isn't
one so it would be great justice to see
her get to be a knight in the Star Wars
universe
so moving on special Star Wars event
happening this Thursday I'll be doing a
video for it so no worries
it's Dave Filoni from the rebels cartoon
and it's called Star Wars past present
and future it's mostly going to be a
talk about the evolution of storytelling
at Lucasfilm as it applies to you know
all the new Star Wars stuff that's
happening my video for that will
probably post Thursday afternoon and if
you already subscribed to my channel
then you can also follow me on social
off links
so that at the bottom of the description
I'll probably live tweet it and moving
on to Star Wars spin-offs so don't be
surprised if every time they make an
episode 7 announcement like JJ Abrams
made with that clever picture they make
a spin-off announcement the big news is
they've just hired josh trank to do
another one of the spin-offs so right
now they have Gareth Edwards doing one
and josh trank doing another leaving one
more director to pick originally
Lawrence Kasdan and Simon Kinberg were
each gonna do one but one of them might
have had to drop out because of
scheduling conflicts josh trank is
mostly known for directing Chronicle and
he's also doing the upcoming Fantastic
Four reboot either way there hasn't been
official word on who's doing which
spin-off or which one is coming first
but my earlier theory was that Gareth
Edwards was doing the read five movie
first so I guess I'll say josh trank is
either doing boba fett or Han Solo also
in case I haven't mentioned it earlier
we don't know if the spin-offs are
either gonna be prequels or origin
stories or if they're gonna just take
place sequentially in the timeline of
the new trilogy the really cool thing
about the Josh Trank news is that he
actually did a short Star Wars fan film
in 2007 called stabbing at Leia's it
actually helped him get his first big
job directing Chronicle for Fox the film
actually looks a lot like Chronicle
ended up being with shaky-cam and this
really in real life look I think of it
as kind of like a dude bro fight with
lightsabers the Fantastic Four reboot
that he's working on is actually
scheduled for release June 2015 because
that movies so soon they might end up
having to reschedule it or he might just
not start working on the Star Wars
spin-off until next year whatever post
prediction on Fantastic Four is done
that's actually a movie at Fox so you
can see how Studios like to stick with
directors they've already worked with
Star Wars is obviously Disney so if the
spin-off stuff goes really well don't be
surprised if you see Josh Trank doing
more Disney movies in the future I've
also got some news about the new novels
too obviously there's all the expanded
universe stuff that's been going on but
they basically rebooted all of the novel
continuity and they got three ones
coming out in the next year so they're
all gonna take place in the new movie
canon so they'll set up a lot of the
story that's gonna take place during
Episode 7 the first one is Tarkin
obviously about Grand Moff Tarkin that's
coming out later this year and then next
year there's gonna be two books the
first one is called
heir to the Jedi and the second one is
Lords of the Sith the Jedi book is
coming out in January 2015 in the Sith
one in March 2015 so presumably they'll
basically just lead right up directly to
the beginning of episode 7 the Star Wars
rebels cartoon is also part of the new
Canon but that takes place just a couple
years after Return of the Jedi and
episode 7 picks up about 30 years or so
after a Return of the Jedi so obviously
those will be way way far apart in time
I know I haven't done a ton of book
reviews on my channel yet but there are
a ton of books coming out of the next
year that I'm really excited about not
least of which is winds of winter so if
there are any Star Wars Expanded
Universe books or stories that you want
me to do just let me know in the
comments below based on them shoving all
of the expanded universe cannon to the
side I think it's safe to say that any
of the pre established backstories for
Jedi SIF grand moff tarkin are gonna be
redone for these new novels I'm kind of
bummed because I really like the Dark
Horse Comics and the del rey novels I
remember most of what I learned about
grand moff tarkin for instance was
through the Admiral Dalek character I
think the last time she appeared was in
the fate of the Jedi series that was
actually meant to be like a big
transition from the classic characters
to the newer ones like the solo children
and Ben Skywalker that's actually kind
of funny because all those novels were
playing before Disney bought Star Wars
so all that's getting pushed to the side
- the only other rumor that I wanted to
include in this video is actually for
Indiana Jones Disney's making plans for
a new franchise and Robert Pattinson s'
the favorite to take over the role I'm
sure that is going to inspire a ton of
hate or a ton of love depending on where
you fall on the Robert Pattinson
spectrum but remember special Star Wars
event happening this Thursday I'm also
doing Fault in Our Stars and edge of
tomorrow this week so lots of fun stuff
happening right now click here to learn
more about the Boba Fett spin-off and
click here to learn about my top 10
picks for the new Doctor Strange movie
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives
you